all right Facebook pulled dozens of
apparently fake accounts amid new
concerns about Russian efforts to
undermine the upcoming midterm elections
Facebook said yesterday it had deleted
32 counts and pages possibly tied to a
Kremlin backed disinformation campaign
many pages stoked political differences
and racial tensions vladimir duthiers of
our streaming network cbsn is following
this unfolding story live good morning
good morning facebook says the accounts
were created between march 2017 and May
2018 by people who went to great lengths
to hide their true identity the company
suggests the efforts to hack American
democracy are not only ongoing but
they're getting more sophisticated many
of the deleted pages inflamed divisions
and encouraged Americans to turn on each
other
an account called re sisters even duped
real people into organizing a protest in
Washington DC billed as a sequel to the
confrontations with white nationalists
that took place last year in
Charlottesville Virginia violence that
left one protester dead in a conference
call Facebook CEO Sheryl Sandberg said
the DC protest which is still planned
for next week prompted the company to
act security is an arms race we face
determined well-funded adversaries who
won't give up and who are constantly
changing tactics Facebook couldn't link
the fake pages to Russia with 100%
certainty but the digital trail appears
to lead back to Moscow post often
contain grammatical errors
characteristic of Russian speakers
according to security analysts working
with Facebook at one point an
administrator of the resisters page was
an account linked to a Russian troll
farm called the internet research agency
this is really a hack of Facebook it's
more of a hack of our minds dan
Patterson is a technology reporter at
CNN why is it so hard for Facebook to
identify whether or not it is Russia in
this particular instance the actors use
what's called a VPN that's a virtual
private network this makes it very
difficult for forensic investigators to
really determine down to a fine science
who precisely was involved but lawmakers
briefed by Facebook sounded convinced
what we're
looking at in social media is an effort
by the Russians and potentially other
adversaries to create social chaos to
divide America the National Security
Council told CBS News its coordinating
the government-wide response to foreign
interference in US elections homeland
security secretary kirsten nielsen
warned yesterday that cyber threats are
now a bigger danger to the US than
physical attacks that's where we are we
know if the government identified it to
Facebook or whether Facebook identified
it they're not it's Facebook that
identified it the problem of course is
that they're using these VPNs yes and
it's every time they try to identify it
they change locations so it's hard to
know exactly where they're coming from
yeah it's a constantly changing weather
front right indeed
thank you glad